sacha baron cohen donc qui étaient là
hier voilà celui il m'a envoyé un petit
cadeau regardez venez prendre au cacao
s'il vous plaît si quelqu'un pouvait
lire ils m'ont volé un cadeau
aujourd'hui regardés avec sa voix là il
m'a envoyé ça aujourd'hui m'a fait
vibrer ça voilà pour mon poignet
voyez voilà du médicament tout ça et il
m'a mis un mot et imap il m'a offert
également un gâteau il m'a envoyé un
gâteau c'est la casse le gars avec des
clés dessus
apparemment c'est le personnage d'ali
baba
it was great to be on est au chaud à y
faire
oui oh oui à la connection a world was
almost all blacks et bâle
bizarre bizarre sacha voilà
[Rires]
de rien mais vous le dire
[Applaudissements]
l'auteur
mon club ou d'armor allez on va jouer
tout de suite action pour annoncer
partie digne
[Applaudissements]
c'est un garçon c'est un des garçons les
plus généreux que je connaisse et donc
on s'est dit aujourd'hui on va faire un
truc on va s'amuser mais on va aussi
donner de l'argent pour une association
dont l'écran il y a neuf cases des 15 à
50 euros 100 euros 200 euros 500 euros
et on va essayer de faire le plus de
choses possible mais pas dans la veille
six résidents dans la veste chemise
c'est pas la petite bête qui va me bats
ont dû me nots et surtout les soirs
secondes et à la soif
[Rires]
les étoiles qu'elle coule et tu pouvais
pas savoir où yahoo retient-il et battu
sa subtile et il a cumulé autre accident
on y va vite ses premiers voulaient pas
être pas mal et ça fait un cri de
goélands j'ai eu plusieurs vies sur ma
vie que j'ai une hydrocution lac au
début j'étais chaud
[Applaudissements]
oui
bref
m
[Applaudissements]
dans les faits parce que vivant dit il
en a garoché des serpents géants boîte
de nuit on entend la semaine dernière
son père superbe vallée je me mets pour
le garde oui bah ouais ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
là il ya john questionner
alors non ses quatre soeurs j'ai pas
très bien vu bon je le mets dans mes
chevaux et puis on verra ça c'est rien
par celle de leurs maux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
allez-y gérard louvin vous vous posez le
crapaud sur la tête 12 oh [ __ ]
attention attention vase
10h18 17 13 12 aux dix neuf et vous lui
c'est une blague très mignon sera po on
est vraiment mais tout s'est passé je le
fais pour la salle et on gagne le reste
et je mets 100 euros la passe que 50
euros j'avale c'est à dire
[Applaudissements]
trois gains à l'egypte au caire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
habitat lucas erika et il reste à vous
et retarde la nuit erika y voilà moi
j'adore le taux de suicide moi j'adore
ça
alors en fait faut mettre ce qui suit
cela c'est bon c'est mon truc préféré
faudrait qu'un tissu cela faut taper là
il faut mettre le tissu zabou sommet
c'est quoi je le faire aussi parce que
j'ai demandé à tout le monde fait des
trucs dégueulasses et moi j'ai fait
chaud et dac hyp et je n'ai pas
souhaitable que j'essaie de faire
attention attention voilà mon chéri et
apprendre à turin camille combal
attention c'est parti
1 il faut taper d'un coup sec moquer
d'après hé bah ça saute et après on
essaie de le récupérer attention tu veux
tu va démarrer tu veux des mariés marc
vazy et du mal attention blues aux
rockets c'est de la croûte de porte
[Rires]
cinquante ans attention attention je
sais que je peux y arriver à l'achat
jeudi soir ok ce mardi
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait
bronfman
[Applaudissements]